[Musique]
je pense je suis même presque persuadé
que les les les chocs émotionnels
profond ou grave que nous pouvons
rencontrer dans notre vie peuvent être
la source de formidables changement
positif pour cette dernière est pour
notre place sur cette planète
je m'explique quand j'avais 15 ans ma
grand mère qui était terriblement pieuse
dans la religion très catholique très
croyante m'emmener à la messe très
régulièrement et dont j'étais très
proche pendant toute ma jeunesse ma
grand mère décède
elle décède avec un courage qui me
laisse perplexe
premier choc émotionnel de ma vie je me
pose la question de la religion de la
spiritualité
quelques années plus tard j'ai 22 ans je
suis sur les bancs de l'école et à 22
ans un camarade qui a le même âge que
moi étaient rasées par une tumeur au
cerveau et je me pose là la question de
notre petitesse de notre fragilité du
sens de ce qu'on est et de la chance
qu'on a d'être en vie et que cette
chance est très fragile quelques années
plus tard ma compagne avec qui je
partageais ma première compagne qui je
partageais six ans de vie commune et
avec qui j'étais destinée à avoir une
vie belle et heureuse comme dans les
contes de fées m'annonce un 24 décembre
qu'elle me quitte pour aller dans les
bras d'un autre choc émotionnel je me
pose la question du de l'amour de la vie
à deux la vie de couple
quelques années plus tard encore mon
père décède 64 ans d'un cancer
entrepreneurs ils travaillent dix heures
par jour de 8h à 20h ça fait même 12
quelques temps de repas quand même mais
bon travailleur acharné il décède à
l'âge de 64 ans
où il pourrait commencer à profiter et
là je me pose la question du travail est
la plus récemment encore un collègue et
ami avec qui je travaille depuis 17 ans
18 ans maintenant fait un avc dans mon
bureau de mon entreprise on et collègues
et on l'emmène tous aux urgences et
toute la petite équipe ici à caen on
l'emmène aux urgences et en attendant la
salle d'urgence de savoir s'il s'en sort
heureusement il s'en sort mais je me
pose là encore une question la question
de ma responsabilité en tant
qu'entrepreneur la responsabilité
sociale bref quand j'ai préparé de ce
thé d'aix
mon ami m'a dit mais quelle ville merten
finalement j'ai pas une vie de merde
plus que vous vous traversez exactement
les mêmes épreuves les mêmes choc
émotionnel
je pense qu'on traverse tous ces
épreuves ce qui est intéressant c'est ce
qui vient peut-être ensuite moi quand
j'ai analysé un petit peu tout ces chocs
émotionnels au fur et à mesure que ça
arrive et je me suis rendu compte que il
y avait des modèles sociétaux qui était
là depuis toujours et qu'on nous avait
servi
telle une soupe depuis qu'on était tout
petit et pour tous les grands domaines
de la vie par exemple je parlais de la
spiritualité la spiritualité
elle est accaparé depuis des dizaines et
des centaines d'années par les religions
alors certes je pouvais avoir le choix
faire comme ma grand-mère prendre le
catholicisme j'ai même le mode d'emploi
qui va avec c'est magnifique mais
j'étais pas forcément d'accord avec ça
et je suis rendu compte que ce n'était
pas forcément évident de changer de
modèle et de changer les modèles surtout
quand ils étaient partagés
collectivement
pareil dans la vie de couple on a un
modèle sociétal qui est déjà pré établi
le prince qui rencontre la princesse ou
la princesse qui rencontre le prince
ils se marient
ont beaucoup d'enfants achète un
pavillon un monospace à labrador une
gamelle pour le chien et les croquettes
qui va demain pareil moi j'ai toujours
eu un peu de mal avec ce genre de modèle
et surtout avec le choc émotionnel que
j'ai vécu j'ai préféré sortir un peu des
sentiers battus et j'ai préféré basé ma
relation avec ma compagne actuelle par
exemple plus sur le partage de projets
plus que sur le partage de promesses et
puis vient la question justement du
travail
la question du sens de ce qu'on pouvait
faire 7 8 heures 9 heures par jour dans
un bureau
je parle pour moi mais je pense qu'on a
beaucoup d'entre nous qui travaillons
dans des bureaux
mais peu importe de ce qu'on fait
pendant 7 8 heures 9 heures par jour je
me suis posé la question de est-ce qu'on
était est-ce que j'étais pas en train de
suivre ce modèle sociétal de oui jérémie
tu vas sortir d'une à l'école tu vas
voir un bon petit cdi tu vas devenir
cadre d'une entreprise puis tu vas
gagner de l'argent ça tombe bien ça te
permettra d'acheter ce pavillon ce
monospace ce chien la gamelle et les
croquettes qui vont dans et là aussi je
me suis dit est-ce que je rende pas dans
ce modèle de société où on a transformé
l'être par la voir est ce que finalement
on n'est pas tous en train de travailler
plus pour avoir que pour être en rapport
avec ce qu'on est réellement
effectivement comme art il a dit tout à
l'heure
peut-être un petit peu atypique dans mon
style d'entrepreneurs ou de travailleurs
je ne sais pas mais effectivement j'ai
remis un petit peu tous ces modèles
classiques en question et j'ai décidé de
me raccrocher à l'essentiel gm décidé
par exemple d'habiter plutôt dans une
petite cabane en bois de 19 mètres
carrés plutôt que dans mon pavillon de
100 mètres carrés
j'ai décidé parce que ça avait du sens
pour moi de faire deux mois de colonies
de vacances parce que j'étais au contact
des autres et que je pouvais transmettre
aux plus jeunes et échanger
et apprendre j'ai décidé récemment avec
ma compagne actuelle de me lancer dans
la permaculture depuis quelques mois on
plante des choux ça va la faire rire a
même pas que je me dis ça par la
rhubarbe on va dire laframboise aussi
j'apprends la permaculture
et puis la boulangerie et ainsi de suite
je fais un tas de choses et j'ai décidé
également d'arrêter de travailler dix
heures par jour dans mon bureau
si j'avais besoin que 3 4 heures et que
le reste du temps j'étais peut-être plus
utile à faire quelque chose qu'ils
avaient du sens pour moi alors voilà où
je en arriver je me dis finalement tout
ce que j'ai fait samar connecter à
l'essentiel et ça je vous pose la
question si vous essayez de fermer vos
yeux et de vous souvenir des meilleurs
moments de votre vie
faites le test vous verrez tout de suite
ou plus tard que les meilleurs souvenirs
de votre vie ce n'est ce n'est
certainement pas ce ne sont certainement
pas sous vous avez possédé quelque chose
vous allez acheter quelque chose ce
n'est certainement pas la nouvelle
voiture ou la nouvelle boucle d'oreille
conz a offert à noël vous allez voir que
les meilleurs moments de votre vie pour
vous reconnecter à l'essentiel ce sont
souvent des moments que vous avez
partagé avec les autres ou reconnecter à
l'essentiel qu'est notre planète
la nature souvent c'est une balade en
forêt un super coucher de soleil
cette randonnée que j'ai fait en
montagne je suis arrivé au bout ou alors
ce repas en famille ou entre copains et
de là finalement je me suis aperçu que
tous les changements que j'avais opéré
dans ma vie il me reconnecter à
l'essentiel qui était la nature notre
planète et ça tombe bien parce que le
plus grand défi auquel on fait face
aujourd'hui c'est celui de sauver la
planète
effectivement dans quelques décennies si
on ne prend pas les choses en main dès
maintenant
effectivement notre planète n'existera
peut-être plus alors je me suis dit que
si ces petits changements positifs pour
ma vie finalement alors c'était
provoquées par des chocs émotionnels
très grave mais des changements positifs
pour l' équilibre de ma vie avait un
impact intensément soit peu
positif pour la sauvegarde de notre
planète
et si je rejoignis une petite communauté
parce que je suis loin d'être le seul et
je suis loin d'être un modèle dans ce
domaine là mais si je rejoins cette
communauté je me dis si c'est un petit
impact quidsi un grand groupe pétrolier
le faisait quid si un grand constructeur
automobile faisait la même chose
quid c'est l'éducation l'éducation
nationale le faisait alors je vous pose
ce défi parce que demain vous avez vous
pouvez vous aller avoir votre réveil va
sonner
vous allez au travail et je vous pose
cette question
2 est ce que ce que vous êtes ce que
vous allez faire là au travail demain
pendant sept heures de votre journée a
réellement un sens prouve et plus
largement
est ce que l'entreprise ou la
collectivité pour laquelle vous allez
travailler
elle respecte sa responsabilité sociale
et environnementale
est ce qu'elle est dans cette démarche
de sauver le monde parce que si nous
petits individus on a un petit impact
imaginez ce que ça donne si toutes les
entreprises font face à leurs
responsabilités
alors à vous de décider si vous avez
envie de faire partie d'une entreprise
coupables ont peut-être plus une
entreprise solutions
si vous n'avez plus envie de travailler
dans l'exploitation ou plutôt dans
quelque chose de plus raisonnée est ce
que vous avez envie de faire partie
d'une entreprise coupable ou d'une
entreprise solutions
telle est ma question ce soir et si nous
petites pme de normandie de parier deux
camps on a réussi avec quelques
individus a changé beaucoup de choses
alors que nous n'en sommes qu'au début
alors que nous en sommes qu à
l'initiation si nous avons réussi à
réduire nos déchets
nos impressions de 80% si on a mis un
petit con poste de bureau qu'on partage
avec le restaurant en bas de notre
bureau
et si nous venons de lancer une
plateforme pour justement mettre en
relation des jeunes qui cherchent du
sens dans leur vie professionnelle avec
des entreprises qui veulent sauver le
monde
cette fameuse plateforme it make sense
si nous on avance ou nous avons réussi
avec notre petite entreprise
alors c'est faisable partout à vous de
relever ce défi et individuels de partir
de vos choc émotionnel pour changer vos
propres vies mais au-delà de ça allait
plus loin convaincre les autres convainc
que la société et les modèles
économiques doivent faire face à leurs
responsabilités sociales et
environnementales et c'est comme ça et
c'est la seule solution si demain nous
voulons sauver le monde
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]